Apple Needs Samsung,
let me put that another way.
Apple needs someone to manufacture the
oled screens on it's brand new,
flagship smartphone,
the iphone 10 and Samsung.
It's biggest smartphone competitor is
the only company that can do it.
If you're wondering how Samsung stock
price could look like this in a year
when the company had to replace them,
fully recall and exploding phone in a
year when it's defacto.
Chief Executive was sentenced to five
years in jail for bribery and
embezzlement.
This is how most people know Samsung as
the company that sells them smartphones
and tvs,
even refrigerators,
but the strongest part of its business
is actually the components it builds for
other companies,
namely memory chips and displays like
the old display that's going into the
iphone 10 in these two key divisions.
Samsung has the ability to supply
products quickly to meet a Gargantuan
worldwide demand.
The name of the game is market share
that they of course supply their own
devices with these components,
but they want everyone else to turn to
them too and they're investing heavily,
almost $19,000,000,000
on new plants in the next four years to
grab a bigger slice of that pie.
In July of this year,
Samsung overtook Intel as the world's
number one chip maker and their
dominance and owlette is even more
extreme.
As of the beginning of 2017,
Samsung had over 90 percent of the
market share,
basically a monopoly,
which means when demand for Olin grows
like it has with the iphone.
Samsung groves to apple,
you might guess hates the situation
because Samsung is the only old lead
maker in the world who can handle the
demand for new iphones.
Samsung gets to set the price for
reference.
Kgi Securities estimates that Samsung
will charge apple around 120 to $130 for
each oled screen compared to old lcd
screens which only cost apple about 45
to $55 and this may be a contributor to
the hefty $1,000
price tag on the iphone 10.
This sort of thing has to,
especially Tim Cook,
Apple Ceo Cooks,
expertise is in supply chain in the
process of how products get made and
distributed to customers and when he
joined apple in 1998,
he was instrumental in overhauling the
supply chain and making it the most
efficient in the world.
One of the ways apple does this is by
outsourcing pretty much all of its
production to suppliers mostly in Asia
who compete for their business,
but in the case of oled screens,
apple has no other choice but to go with
Samsung.
Apple wanted 80 million oled screens
just for the second half of 2017.
No one else can do that.
Samsung barely has the capacity,
which is one of the reasons why the
iphone 10 comes out six weeks later than
the iphone eight in order to bring its
own lead costs down.
Apple needs for there to be a serious
competitor in this space,
which is why it's investing two point
$7,000,000,000
in LG display.
Basically a massive cash advance for
them to build up their capacity.
Google has the same idea.
It's investing $880 million dollars in
to lg to break the Samsung monopoly for
the near future,
though it doesn't quite matter,
Samsung is likely to be the major
beneficiary of apple's lead needs,
at least through 2019.
Not to mention that we'll also be making
a huge number of theories.
Chips for apple to know.
It's one of the strangest relationships
in business.
Apple and Samsung have been feuding for
years ever since 2010 when Samsung
essentially copied the iphone with their
galaxy s smartphone.
The two companies have been locked in
illegal war for almost seven years.
That has cost Samsung $150,
million dollars and maybe more.
In the end,
it seems silly because apple is still
shelling out millions upon millions to
its archrival for parts bolstering
Samsung's huge profits and its growth.
The iphone x is sort of the perfect
symbol for the whole messy relationship
and it captures how the tech business
works at the very highest level.
It's dysfunctional marriages like this.
Apple Needs Samsung.
Yeah,
but Samsung is certainly profiting from
the business.
In other words,
these two mega companies really need
each other.
Everybody.
Thank you so much for watching.
This episode was brought to you by
squarespace.
If you want to make a website and you
want it to be a really easy process,
squarespace has some beautiful award
winning designer templates to choose
from.
That makes the process so simple.
It's got 24 hour customer service,
no upgrades,
nothing to install,
no patches ever,
and picking your domain name is really
easy.
You can start your free
trial@squarespace.com,
and if you use the offer code
nerdwriter,
you can get 10 percent off your first
purchase.
Thanks guys.
I'll see you next time.